am I nervous about the surgery honestly
not
not really this is going to sound this
is and this is not of what was me thing
but I even uh when talking with my
therapist told her like oh man I would
love to have one of my favorites like do
you think you could have a period where
you can like take a full month or take a
you know a couple months off because
that's important for someone to do in a
high compression scenario and I thought
oh
if I just have like some serious health
problem then I could take time off and
people wouldn't be mad at me like you
know you can read the comments be like
oh it's like because when we're taking
time off we'll spend that you know we're
not we're not really taking time off
like sometimes it'll take several weeks
to upgrade the studio to make sure that
we have software licenses like we have
the work that people see is such a small
fraction that I haven't actually taken
like a long vacation in a while
and this will be the closest to that
only I'll have you know three titanium
rods in my chest and a lot of pain but
hopefully that's what painkillers are
for I was just trying to make sure that
I fit the pieces